pas merci d'être avec nous on vous
invite parce que vous connaissez bien le
monde du divertissement
las vegas notamment le sport la mode le
baseball qui est annulé à montréal il
doit y avoir deux matchs des blue jays
continue qu'ils de niort quand je parle
de divertissement on parle du cirque du
soleil également
et tout le monde de l'investissement est
ce que vous avez déjà vu une chose
pareille
et comment vous pouvez qualifier
l'impact que ça aura que l'annulation de
tous ces événements malheureusement ses
démons nécessaire je pense pour la
prévention de propagation de virus donc
je pense que le premier ministre de
gauche ainsi que d autres leaders
reprises les autres hommes et femmes en
charge
on fait des bonnes décisions tonkam mais
quand même c'est difficile on peut en
pense on pense d de sport on pense de la
ligue nationale de hockey
mais on ne pense pas des travailleurs
des personnes qui travaillent dans les
arénas
on parle des compagnies de croisières
deux qui sont arrêtées complètement
aujourd'hui toutes leurs activités de
croisière une compagnie qui a trente
mille employés royaux creux viennent s'y
arrêtent ils ont 80 mille employés donc
on peut penser des passagers qui vont
pas avoir de vacances mais on pense moi
je pense toujours aux employés ont
travaillé et ça va être très très dur
pour trait pour beaucoup de monde pour
un bout de temps mais vous qui voulez
investir dans le hockey professionnel à
6 attolou dans le baseball professionnel
à montréal
il me semble que tu as un impact
incroyable parce que l'économie du
divertissement du sport de la culture
c'est quand même une économie très
important c'est sûr que la guerre avec
les droits de télévision avec tout les
droits de commandite si tu prends le
cirque du soleil par exemple on fait
presque 100 % de nos revenus annuels par
des ventes de billets on vend table
ronde à peu près 12 millions de billets
pour à peu près 1.1 milliard de dollars
si on vend d'aucune billet on n'a aucune
revenus pour une bhoutan c'est à dire
que ça va avoir un impact énorme à et
donc s'il est clair qu'il y aura un
impact énorme pour le cirque du soleil
je pense qui est clair que à plusieurs
de nos de noah production qui font le
tour du monde actuel sont annulées ou en
train d'être annulée le futur de
vieillesse
proche futur devait que cet inconnu mais
ça commence à apparaître que on va voir
on va passer une période très difficile
pour les employés de la compagnie si on
se trouve son show pour un bouton
l'entreprise est en très bonne santé
donc c'est temporaire mais quand même on
sait pas pour combien de temps on est
dans cette situation là mais
l'entreprise déjà été affectés dès le
départ en chine où elle a dû annuler ses
spectacles mais ça ça fait partie de
notre de notre business donc on a déjà
eu des des des attaques terroristes à
paris donc ça a affecté paris on avait
là le tac à vegas
ça a affecté vegas jamais qu'on a eu une
situation où ce affecte tous les shows
dans tous les villes et tous les pays
dans le monde où on fait le tour
donc oui la chine était un pays
problématiques mais c'est un pays
problématiques parliez des travailleurs
tantôt est ce que vous pensez qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens dans le milieu du sport
dans le milieu de la culture qui vont
perdre leur emploi dans les prochaines
semaines
je pense que perdre leur emploi non à
des mises à pied j'ai entendu le premier
ministre legault aujourd'hui qu'ils
parlaient que demain ou après demain il
va annoncer des mesures pour des
compagnies et des gens qui vont soit
perdre leur emploi ou seront mises à
pied ou les compagnies qui vont souffrir
problèmes de liquidités dont il va avoir
des programmes gouvernementaux et je
pense que on doit les avoir si on envoie
les gens à la maison par exemple mais
ils peuvent pas travailler à la maison
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire
si tout le monde reste à la maison
qu'est ce qui va arriver avec tous les
restaurants avec tous les magasins donc
le monde affecté ça peut il peut y avoir
beaucoup
voilà vous réagissez face à la décision
du président entre hommes par exemple de
fermer les frontières aux européens
certains disent que sur le plan de la
santé publique il faut le faire d'autres
sont pas d'accord avec ça sur le plan
économique à court terme et en effet
c'est très très clair mais vous comme
homme d'affaires qu'est ce que vous en
pensez mais je veux laisser ça aux
médecins donc je peux pas dire que le
président soit parfaite sa décision sur
la base des conseils
des médecins c'est sûr que c'est pas un
virus européen
maintenant c'est un virus qui est
partout dans presque tous les pays dans
le monde
donc on doit tous suivre les prudents
qui nous sont émis à tous les jours par
les médecins je peux pas dire les
motivations pour avoir fermé les
frontières et pas fermer les frontières
du royaume uni aux états unis où il ya
tant de cas au royaume-uni que dans
plusieurs pays dans l'union européenne
donc j'ai pas compris la geste mais je
sais pas non plus comment es tu arrivé à
cette vision là comme président
d'investir au canada est ce que ça vous
inquiète pour l'économie canadienne
non pas vraiment parce que ça c'est
vraiment court terme nous on cherche des
investissements à très long terme ça va
nous affecter nos activités par exemple
l'explo l'expo globale est à dubaï et
vinvin très important pour le canada
pour avoir pour aller à tirer
d'investissements de l'étranger
peut-être ce vote annulé je sais pas
mais si je suis je regarde comment les
choses se déroulent actuellement salaire
que ça va être affectée donc non mais
pour l'investissement au canada je suis
pas inquiète
je sais pas si je peux vous demander ça
mais pour un homme prospère irish comme
vous est ce que la chute boursière vous
fait mal aux papas c'est sûr qu'il ya
personne à qui fait pas mal savez
présente aussi une opportunité
si on regarde dans l'histoire d'un
historique à les chutes quand tu comme
aujourd'hui ça représente des
opportunités
si j'étais un investisseur j'en suis un
jeu
je me rends très un petit peu
aujourd'hui peut-être un petit peu de
mains mais il faut pas se il faut pas
trop engagé dans une journée où dans une
semaine parce qu'on sait vraiment pas où
ça va aller est-ce que la bosse pour
chuter un autre 5 mais notre demand est
ce que ça peu est-ce que c'est pas
revenir la semaine prochaine
on le sait pas mais on voit des
compagnies avec thé avec des bilans très
forts qui ont des entreprises très
fortes qui vont revenir très fort hiller
leur cote de leurs actions est très bas
donc ça représente
il y en a des bonnes opportunités
aujourd'hui je carbure faisait président
d'investir au canada président du soleil
et entrepreneurs on reconnaît bien merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation soit si
je rate merci